- Hey guys, how's it going?
It's Justine and today
we are in my kitchen
and I have a very, very special guest.
- Hello.
- This is the one,
the only, iPhonedo!
(laughs)
- Hello.
- So, thanks so much for coming.
- Thank you for having me.
- We had quite the adventure this morning.
- We did.
- So we both
ordered flame throwers.
And then what did we do this morning?
- Well, we went to pick it up
because they said that they
were gonna have this party
and then we were gonna be able to play
with the flamethrowers and
pick up our own flamethrower.
- [Justine] Well, we picked it up.
They also had a little demo
thing, a lot of things happened.
Here is a quick little vlog clip of it.
Capri Sun and churros.
(flame thrower hissing)
- There you go!
- All right so we just had like a really
really bad experience,
like nothing was working
and they like kicked us out and said,
"Sorry only one person."
And I'm like, "but it
didn't actually work!"
- [Man Off Screen]
You're not the only one!
- Yeah, no, everybody was
having problems with it, we did that one
over there and it was great!
- I'm so sad, well, at least yours worked.
- Yeah, it was great.
- That's good, that's good.
So it didn't quite work out
as well as I had planned,
but it's okay because now we're here.
- Now, we're here.
- We have it in my house, and guess what?
We're going to do an unboxing!
(laughter)
I should probably get an unboxing knife.
- Hmm.
(happy music)
(door slides open)
- Okay!
(laughter)
- I made spaghetti with
this the other day.
Do you think this is useful?
- Please tell me you watch Forged In Fire.
- No. What's the reference?
I don't watch many things.
- "This will cut."
- I'm only laughing-
- So if you know what I'm
talking about, let me know.
- I'm only laughing because I don't
get the reference, but it does cut.
So we've got some instructions here.
This is the manual that came with it.
It is actually Not-A-Flamethrower.
Usually I don't read directions,
but I feel like maybe we should this time.
- Maybe for this one, it can be helpful.
- There's a lot of things in here
like this, here's
everything that is on it.
We've got the nozzle, the ignition switch,
the trigger, the regulator,
the propane tank,
the idle valve and the fuel bracket.
This is Not-A-Flamethrower.
- It is that.
- Why not?
- For legal reasons.
(laughter)
- In all of the emails our lawyers made us
say this, which makes sense, because
this thing is pretty intense.
Purchasing propane, mounting
propane, troubleshooting.
Let's open.
I don't think I need this.
- No, but, you know.
(laughter)
- Duh, da, duh, da, duh, da! Whoa!
Not-A-Flamethrower
(perky happy music)
What do you think?
- I think it's pretty impressive.
- What did you think when you bought this?
- I thought it was going to be more
like a decorative, like, "ha,
ha, ha, yes there is this
"little fire coming out."
And when I saw what it can do
during the pick-up event,
I was pretty amazed
and a little worried maybe.
- [Justine] We both were concerned.
- [iPhonedo] Because a
lot of people bought it.
(flames snapping)
What?
My house is definitely
catching on fire today!
- Do you want to help
me with the other side?
- Yes.
- This is really heavy.
- Yes it is.
(groans)
- Wow!
So first we've got, um,
oh look here's the serial number.
- Yeah.
- I am one, three, four, seven.
Why was I not one, three, three, seven?
We should have requested it.
Let's take this out of here.
It's heavier than I remember.
That's it.
- That's it, nothing else.
- That's exciting.
So it uses a standard
14.1 ounce propane tank.
Attach the propane tank through
(Whispers)
- Okay, let's do it.
- I just--
- What's the worst thing that can happen?
- I mean, honestly, do we have
a fire extinguisher handy?
- [Cameraman ] Oh, yeah, one sec.
- I mean that flame we saw earlier
was aggressive but they said that it was
potentially because of the wind.
- Are you going to go for it or the plan?
(laughter)
What's the expiration date on that?
- Do they expire?
- Oh yeah.
- Really?
I think it's fine, it's fine.
Fire extinguisher is handy in the back.
And now we're just going to do this.
Take this off of here, jam this in here,
who sold me this?
Are they crazy?
(clicking)
- As far as I've seen,
it doesn't last long.
- I'm going to have to pull
some propane. (clicking)
- Oh! I almost got your finger!
- No, no.
- Okay, so those little
arrows that say on, off.
When we were at the demo they said,
R.I.T. was something that
we needed to remember.
- Regulator, Ignite and then Trigger.
- [Cameraman ] Please don't
point it toward the light.
If the diffusion hits it
will just go, so try not--
(laughter)
- And if that happens, you need to be on,
you've got to get the shot.
We put the fire out you
have to keep filming.
- [Cameraman ] Of course.
- This seems to be all
screwed in, is there
anything else I should know?
I don't think so.
I think this is a very simple thing
and I'm over-complicating it like usual.
- What did we agree on?
- Did we sign our lives away?
- Uh, I will not use
this in a house, oh okay.
- Wait, really?
- Yeah.
- Does it say I won't use
it in a house? (laughter)
- I will not point this at my spouse,
I will not use this in an unsafe way.
- Oh, we're using it very safe.
- Yeah, we're safe.
- We're being safe, we
have a fire extinguisher.
- Totally controlled environment.
- Yeah!
- What if we go outside and
do the first one outside?
- [Cameraman ] Yeah, test to
see where it's going to come from.
- Yeah.
- And then--
- Okay, we're going to
test this outside first
because now I got nervous.
(laughter)
- and then we'll come back.
- Yeah.
- Ignite.
(hissing)
(gas hissing)
- Wow! Oh, jeez! Oh God!
(flame hissing)
Wow!
(laughter)
- Oh wow! Wow!
It doesn't seem like it's been--
- As soon as I turn this on it
starts coming out from there.
- That's weird.
(hissing)
Like the trigger automatically like...
Oh, my goodness! Flaming!
This is ridiculous!
Now I see why they told me
not to use this in a house.
(flame hissing)
Turn off!
We can't use this inside.
- No.
(laughter)
- [Cameraman ] Not a chance.
- We can't use this inside.
That's not an option.
Okay, well it worked, it's unboxed,
stay tuned for a cooking video.
Because I'm going to try to
cook with a flamethrower.
And I was going to try and shoot this
in my kitchen, but there's absolutely
no way we can do that.
Oh my god!
(flame hissing)
- You get it?
[Cameraman ] Yes.
- How do we do this so
we don't burn each other?
- If I stand here.
- Yeah, maybe, because
this is super dangerous.
How's that, is that far
enough do you think?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Let's do this.
Okay, so propane on, ignite,
(flame bursts)
I didn't even hit the trigger!
- That's what I was telling you.
(flame bursts)
- I'm so happy!
♪ Somebody call nine, one, one ♪
♪ Shawty somethin' somethin' somethin' ♪
♪ on the dance floor ♪
♪ Whoa-A-oh ... ♪
(flame bursts)
- Oh wow.
Alright, let's turn it off.
Off, off.
(flame bursts)
The things that have
happened in this backyard.
(laughter)
- So we're back inside now and I'm really
glad you said we probably should
try this outside first.
- Yeah, me too, really glad.
I'm really glad we didn't do it inside.
- One thing I'm surprised is that
this was five hundred dollars this was not
a cheap thing, and I
thought it was going to be
a little more like, a little more quality.
For a five hundred dollar flame thrower,
that's not actually a flamethrower.
With all that being said,
it's really freakin' cool!
- It looks super cool.
- It looks amazing.
- Yeah.
- Do not use this indoors!
Do not!
- No, read the terms, they're not joking,
even though it's written
in a joking manner.
- It's pretty serious.
- It's quite serious.
- Well guys, thank you for watching,
I'm going to try to do
a little cooking video
we've got some fun things that we're
going to try to cook
with the flamethrower,
also be sure to check out his channel
I'll put links in the
description to all of
your wonderful social media,
I'm such a big fan so thank
you so much for coming here.
- I'm such a big fan myself.
- We're both big fans of each others.
So this works out perfectly great.
- It does.
- We'll see you guys in the next video.
Wow, this is crazy.
I still can't believe
I didn't get one, three,
three, seven, close.
Okay, so we're going to
go to the hardware store.
We're going to bring our manuals with us.
We should probably
actually buy a couple fire
extinguishers while we're
there, to be honest.
- Yeah, because we have
a fever, and the only
prescription is more flamethrower!
(laughter)
- I was like, is it more cowbell or...
(laughter) All right,
let's hop in the car.
We are on our way to the hardware store
to get ourselves some more propane.
- [iPhonedo] Burn some fire!
- Yeah, we got to cook!
I've got so many random
pieces of meat and s'mores.
Oh! We need to get one
of those metal rod things
that they had at the
event so we can just put
stuff on that and burn it.
- [iPhonedo] Yes.
(clicking repeatedly)
("Fire Water Burn" by Bloodhound Gang)
♪ The roof, the roof,
the roof is on fire ♪
♪ We don't need no water
let the mother burn ♪
♪ Burn mother burn ♪
(heavy pounding guitar)
- Well, hopefully it will be quick,
we just got to get this propane tank.
Welcome, to the hardware store.
Soap! Oh I need some soap.
- They have some propane
here but these are too big.
- Flame friendly ceramic grilling pan!
This is what we need.
- We need this.
- Flame friendly.
- I think we need a cart.
- I think we do too.
(laughter)
What has happened?
There's a grilled cheese basket.
You can't take me anywhere.
Look at this!
- Yes, we need that.
And what we need to do, is for example,
I will hold it like this and you--
- No. No. No.
- Oh, yeah, okay.
(metal pail clatters)
- This is a nice bucket.
- It's a cool bucket.
- Look at this little
chicken on this stand!
We may have to stop at the grocery store
to get a whole chicken like that.
- Oh yeah.
- This video is exponentially getting
either better or worse, I'm not sure.
(laughter)
- If I was a little propane
tank where would I be?
- Do you know if you have
a 14.1 ounce propane tank?
- That would be maybe, I'll be back
with you guys in a moment.
- 14.1 ounce propane tank, 14.1.
There's all kinds of stuff that I see
that I should probably have in my house
like an adult would, but I don't.
Oh, pink tape, wow, that's really pretty.
He said it would be up here by torches.
♪ We don't need no water
let the mother burn ♪
- That's cool.
- I could jam some meat on that.
Oh, those are actual rods.
- Yeah.
Wow, wow, wow. Or should we get this one
because if we slam a steak on this
- Okay
- This might be a little more substantial.
Do you know if you have a
14.1 ounce propane tank?
Oh my gosh, I walked by here four times!
- You want to look down low.
- Thank you! We just got a flame thrower.
We've got a lot of meat to cook.
Oh, should I get a hat?
There's a chicken.
He's $80.00.
- One of the hats made
it down here from there.
- Oh no, he blew away.
I see something else that we might need.
This could actually be even better.
We hang the meat off of here.
- That is true.
- That could actually be better.
Oh, this one's on sale, and I could
use these again and put
flower pots on them.
All right, let's see what else
we can see because this
place is fantastic,
I'm seeing so much stuff.
I still want to get the sand.
Do you go to hardware stores often?
- No.
- Me either.
- No, I'm just like you,
I'm usually at home.
- I'm enjoying this, going outside.
- It is really nice, very
different, I didn't know.
- Do you hear the birds chirping?
- Yeah.
- It's beautiful.
Look at these plants.
I'm not even acting, this is real.
Do you guys have sand?
- Yes, way in the back.
- I don't think that's the type of sand
I'm thinking of, I want like nice sand
that if I had a sandbox
that's what I would put in it.
That's like construction sand.
(shopping cart wheels clatter)
Oh it's over here.
I'm over here.
- [Cameraman ] Did you
guys try that log in?
- Should we look again? But
it said it had jointer sand.
Is that what we want?
What's the difference between jointer sand
and all-purpose sand?
It's all, it's kind of
like all-purpose flour.
Right?
- [Cameraman ] I think
that's just for jointers?
- What does that mean?
- What?
- What's that mean?
- [Cameraman ] You don't
know jointers sand?
- Like drugs?
Wow, sand is heavy!
- May I?
- This is not what I remember as a kid
when my dad would get us
sand to put in the sandbox.
This is like freaking heavy.
Look at this, it's shocking!
I think we have everything.
We have everything and more.
We're getting nuts, this is crazy
oh my gosh, we can't actually eat
the things that we cook.
♪ Let's go to the beach, beach ♪
Maybe I'll start a garden.
- Can I get this?
- No, no., this is the
budget for the video.
(laughter)
- I get to say that I
bought propane for Justine.
(laughter)
- No, no!
- Yeah!
- He just tricked me!
- I did it.
- You tricked me.
- I did it and I was
staring into the camera
as I was doing it.
- Trickery, trickery, trickery.
- Tell me there's no
other event where I get to
say I bought propane for Justine.
(laughter)
♪ We don't need no water let
the mother flamethrower burn ♪
- We'll try
- It's the sand, it's throwing us off.
- Let go!
- Let's go!
- Well, I'm definitely not
going to sleep tonight.
Because I'm going to be editing.
- Yeah, right.
- Like what is this?
It's going to work,
it's going to be great.
(happy upbeat music)
- Thank you.
- Of course.
- Wowwee!
(flame bursting)
Oh my!
Jesus! I can't turn my flamethrower off
- [Cameraman ] Is it on fire?
(happy upbeat music)
(popping and crackling)
- Mine's still on.
(jazzy piano)